foreign
[Applause]
felt like
at home but if you were traveling you
see the people who look exactly like you
the food is very similar to what we eat
the language is the same culture is the
same
[Music]
it's been 75 76 years and we still
haven't found a way to live as a
neighbor together so it's unfortunate
that we got separated
in such a way
that we have never found a way to live
peacefully that's the I think the
biggest we get as well
[Music]
thank you
so much
he came there and they brought Biryani
with them so the home-cooked meal they
thought I'm traveling for so long that I
might be missing the home cooked meals
[Music]
[Applause]
he made a really nice beautiful painting
for me to take with me back to Pakistan
and have them in a home or some place
foreign
[Music]